are you sick of playing the same raid
over and over have you collected enough
chicken dinners that you're able to cure
world hunger on a digital scale or maybe
you just really feel like standing sown
in the the new be soft has the solution
for you
Ghost Recon breakpoint the game where
even the vehicles can't contain their
excitement breakpoint is an online
technical shooter set in an open world
environment in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean in this game you'll playing the
role of a special operatives sent onto
an island to investigate a series of
disturbances through these adventures
you'll be in control of some of the
greatest vehicles and weaponry available
including the new inside drive out
helicopter or dirt bikes containing the
new state-of-the-art rocket-propelled
evacuation systems and if all else fails
give base-jumping a go it's anyone's
guess whether it'll work or not
speaking of which gravity can be a real
drag severely limiting what you can do
and we agree break point does it concern
itself for the basic law of physics and
it's dead likes to keep the user
constantly kissing what could happen
next and wait that's not all order
within 10 minutes of this advertisement
and you'll receive a special limited
edition Highlander chemist in so what
are you waiting for
order now and join the ghosts in free
Aurora from the hands of the cruel yet
ruggedly beautiful Jon Bernthal
[Music]
I realize that could have come off as a
little bit negative towards the game but
there's more be poking fun of some of
the exceedingly humorous bugs that I
encountered over the closed beta weekend
before I go any further a must state
that have thoroughly enjoyed my time in
the beta and for anyone who cares this
video simply my take on how I feel about
breakpoint from what I've seen so far
firstly I generally don't like most bait
as I play in case you couldn't tell by
now my way of enjoying most games
originates from how far I can immerse
myself into the game before I've even
managed to fully test out the gameplay
during most betas you're only here to
test out the gameplay select most games
O's going in somewhat blind not
expecting a huge amount but to my
surprise I ended up hanging around and
sucking up every little bit of content I
could get my hands on well until the
time that the beta finished in the
gameplay alone I consider myself a son
who was all really interested in what
the game had to offer and I have to say
right from the word go I was hooked with
this beta sure a beta is just a beta but
if it's anything to go for for the
future release of this game I can
honestly say I'm now convinced that this
will likely be the game I invest my next
thousand hours or so into
Ghost Recon breakpoint certainly wasn't
without its flaws in fact my unusual
intro only showed a few of these the
game is riddled with bugs both major and
minor
these range from visual glitches to gain
braking UI issues the first thing I
noticed when jumping into the game was
the familiar floaty and responsive
sensation that we had in wild lands
except this one felt a little worse I
understand what they're going for a more
realistic approach to the movement
system but for a video game being too
realistic isn't always what we want life
is hard
don't make us feel some of the same
struggles that we have to deal with that
in the real world it wouldn't hurt if
the character momentum could be tuned
down so it's a little more responsive
and we didn't have the stamina of an old
fat man with asthma however what I think
made up for it and actually had
preferring breakpoint over wildlands is
the cover system this is a massively
unpopular opinion I know the die-hard
fans are hating this new cover system
but for me I always thought this was
somewhat lacking from wildlands I also
found that it helped me control the
movement creeping from cover to cover
the only thing that I would like to see
here is perhaps the option to turn down
the strength of the cover system
sometimes I find myself snapping onto it
when I really didn't want to so maybe a
slider to turn it down or even off would
be nice the vehicle movement is weird
nuff said yet oddly enough I found it
easier to control I spent less time
flipping trucks and killing my teammates
than it did in wild lands
don't worry though I found plenty of
other ways to draw my friends but when
it came to the vehicles they just felt
weird the controls and turning didn't
quite match the type of vehicle as
driving things like the dirtbike felt
stiff to turn at times yet large trucks
could almost spin around on a dime the
supposed weight and responsiveness just
didn't fit each vehicle quite right
in saying that there's still a hell of a
lot of fun most gaming sessions ended up
with us blowing up vehicles and running
them into each other or over cliffs this
was probably my biggest pet peeve in the
beta but it's also likely one of the
easiest fixes to implement firstly I had
no idea how to even start or find a
mission it just wasn't very intuitive
eventually I figured it out
but then I was faced with the same issue
the scrolling wasn't working this meant
I couldn't select certain things when
out in the field and I couldn't visit
places like the shop this is a minor and
will likely get fixed pretty quick but
this is just one of the small bugs that
can leave you with the sour taste in
your mouth it makes you start
questioning whether it's just something
you're doing wrong especially since the
majority of the UI just felt a little
bit unfinished on console it was
sluggish and clunky to use and on PC it
just felt way too zoomed in and oddly
laid out it was like they were trying to
cater to both systems but only went
about half way from each side and then
just kind of take them together they
weren't all like this though the build
screen was pretty easy to navigate and
everything was where you'd expect it to
be there are a lot of options to go
through but after you spend a bit of
time here it all makes sense fairly
quickly
as I said earlier and quite often drawn
to a game well before I even get to sit
down and play it but because I wasn't as
heavily invested into the precursor
wildlands I was here to judge and base
the game off the gameplay alone and as a
mainly solo player
I'm very judgy when it comes to new
games I'm looking to be fully immersed
I'm looking at the replayability how
long before I run out of things to do
how repetitive is it
will I be challenged I'm not saying
people who play in groups aren't looking
for the same thing
but it can be easy to overlook a lot of
things when you're playing with friends
Entertainment has almost always
guaranteed you could be doing the most
mundane thing in the world and still be
having fun with the right people
well I jumped into the beta for the
first time and after fighting with the
movement system and reconfiguring quite
a number of settings and key binds and
then blinked and suddenly I realized
that four hours had passed and I'd
barely scratched the surface I got
myself so invested into the game trying
to get on down with my stealthy self and
that doesn't come naturally to me I'm
usually one of those more impatient
run-and-gun sort of players ask any one
of my usual teammates but I found myself
taking my time pacing out each encounter
planning the most efficient way to take
them down without getting spotted I'd be
the first to admit that this could get
quite repetitive after a while but every
base you had to capture every large
group of enemies or bosses you had to
take down played out very differently
with the varying terrain drones and
helicopters flying overhead and a
different base layouts you'd be forced
to reevaluate each time and one wrong
move could completely change the whole
fight with reinforcements being called
in and enemies bum-rushing you with
grenades and don't even get me started
on the wolves another thing I noticed
while playing is that I've been missing
something for quite a while now a
challenge something that happens in most
RPG games is that you get to a point
where your gear is so strong that the
content you're playing just gets too
easy it's not necessarily that you're
getting bitter it's just that your
weapons and armor are
although breakpoints also knocked
achieve from what we've seen so far it
doesn't look like this will be the case
yes content make it easier but it will
likely be from the players situational
awareness and skill level increasing
over time part of this increased
challenge must be accredited to the
drones in the improved AI system
I can hear a few people scoffing at the
second part of that sentence says not
everyone seems to have liked the AI but
I found it a definite upgrade from the
AI and wildlands the way they
outmaneuvered you and flanked you if you
weren't paying enough attention they
weren't the most unpredictable thing in
the world but they certainly had a more
militaristic feel to them the drones on
the other hand they certainly mix things
up if ever I screwed up and eluded the
enemies it always had something to do
with the drone initially I just saw
these is an easy addition to force the
player into a different style of play
but then I came across the walls in
their little pet drones who somehow were
able to predict every point where I was
shooting next avoiding me quickly and
chaining me down I swear one of them
laughed at me too and let's not forget
the penis just an FYI they're much
easier to take down with friends this
has been another hot topic
unlike previous iterations of the game
RPG elements have been added to break
point personally having only played wild
lands and now breakpoint I like this but
this probably isn't any real surprise as
I love RPGs they give me more of a
reason to continue to play the game and
will likely have me playing even longer
and well after I finished the main
campaign but for people who have been
around the Ghost Recon franchise for a
lot longer than myself are
understandably a little concerned the
word that it takes away from the
original feel of the game and that it's
going down the standard generic industry
path of open-world luda shooters but i
guess time will tell how big apart the
RPG will play
[Music]
breakpoint is buggy it has weird
movement and some of the most painful UI
I've dealt with in a long time but it
has the solid bones of an open-world
tactical shooter I don't think this game
will necessarily be for longtime Ghost
Recon fans from back in the day but I
think that anyone coming from wild lands
or if this is the first game in the
series that you've picked up you'll
enjoy it there are still huge questions
around the potential lack of in-game
which is something that all games of
this type suffer from and personally I
don't think breakpoint will be any
different but this is all just my
opinion based on what I was able to play
of the close beta weekend should you buy
the game I won't actually answer that I
recommend you track the game for
yourself from the open beta that should
be coming out soon I've obviously
developed some sort of connection to the
game now which isn't normal for me there
have only been a handful of games of the
years that have fully invested myself
into and I have high hopes that this
will be one of the next ones a bit of a
different video from me so if this
wasn't quite what you're expecting I'm
certainly not one to review games in
case that wasn't obvious by now but I've
had a lot of questions around my
thoughts of the breakpoint beta so I
thought I'd check this one together plus
it helps me feel bitter about the fact
that I neglected my family for an entire
weekend while I was testing a game oh
and before I go I must thank a couple of
people for the clips I've used at
parthis video and throughout thank you I
am Jenko capes gaming ever gents and
sticks I'll have links to them in the
description thanks for watching and I'll
catch you in the next one Cheers
[Music]